هناك سباق مستمر للحصول على لقاح لـ
covid19 والعلماء يعملون بشكل أسرع من
أي وقت مضى ،
وهو أمر غير مسبوق حقًا ،
فلنلقِ نظرة على بعض التقدم المحرز حتى
الآن ،
هناك 133 فريقًا حول العالم يقومون
بتطوير لقاح
10 في السريرية البشرية  التجارب التي تعني
أنهم يجربونها بالفعل
على البشر. 123 في مراحل ما قبل السريرية
مما يعني أنهم يعملون مع الحيوانات أو
أنهم يعملون في المختبر ،
دعونا نلقي نظرة على مكان
وجود هذه الفرق العشرة في التجارب السريرية
هناك  ثلاثة في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
Moderna inovio و novovax ،
هناك واحد موجود في الولايات المتحدة في شركة Pfizer الألمانية
و bioentec
واحد في المملكة المتحدة وهو
astrazeneca الذي يتعاون
مع جامعة أكسفورد
وهناك خمسة في الصين ،
ومن غير الواضح أي منها سيذهب
أنهي أولًا والأهم من
ذلك أنه من غير الواضح أيًا
منها سيعمل ،
فنحن نعلم أن بعضها لن ينجح
ولهذا السبب لدينا الكثير من
التسديدات على المرمى ، إذا جاز التعبير ، فلنتحدث
استمع إلى ما قاله الدكتور
أنتوني فوسي في المعاهد الوطنية الأمريكية
للصحة حول
هذا
الأمر ، فهذا يعني أنه معرض لخطر الاستثمار ، لذلك
سنبدأ في
تصنيع جرعات من
اللقاحات قبل أن نعرف حتى أن اللقاح
يعمل.  معرفة ما إذا كان فعالاً
أم لا بحلول شهر نوفمبر ،
مما يعني أنه بحلول ذلك الوقت
نأمل أن يكون لدينا ما
يقرب من 100 مليون جرعة عن طريق
التصنيع أثناء قيامهم
بالبحث ، ما يعنيه
ذلك هو أنه إذا نجح اللقاح ،
فيجب أن يكون هناك إمداد  الجرعات جاهزة للاستخدام على
الفور ،
فهذا يعني أيضًا أنه إذا لم تنجح بعض اللقاحات ،
فسيتم إنتاجها أساسًا من
أجل لا شيء ولكن
تقرر أن هذا الأمر يستحق
العناء لمحاولة الحصول على لقاح
كافٍ للعالم بأسره في أقرب وقت ممكن
الآن يتم إحراز هذا التقدم ليس فقط في
اللقاحات ولكن أيضًا في العلاجات من
أنواع مختلفة ،
هناك بعض الأخبار هذا الأسبوع حول
فاموتيدين يعرف الكثير من الناس
فاموتيدين حتى لو لم يفعلوا  لا
أعرفه بهذا الاسم في بعض الأماكن ويباع
تحت الاسم التجاري بيبسيد ، إنه علاج شائع جدًا للحموضة
المعوية
، وكان هناك بعض الاعتقاد بأن هذا
قد يساعد في الواقع ضد
فيروس كورونا ، ما وجده الباحثون
وما نشروه في مجلة طبية
هذا الأسبوع
هو أن  10 من المرضى الذين
تناولوه عندما كانوا في المنزل مريضين بفيروس
كوفيد وجدوا بعض الراحة الآن هذا لا
يعني أن الدواء فعل ذلك ، فربما
كان من الطبيعي أنهم سيتحسنون بشكل طبيعي
على أي حال ، وهو ما
يفعله معظم مرضى كوفيد بشكل خاص إذا
إنهم في المنزل ،
لكن من المحتمل أن يكون الفاموتيدين قد
لعب دورًا ، لذا فهم الآن
يخططون لتجربة سريرية كبيرة
حيث سيحصل نصف المرضى
على فورموديدين ،
وسيحصل نصف المرضى على
دواء وهمي وسيشاهدون  من الأفضل
أن يعود إليك